[Applause]
[Music]
hey friends what up Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain uh in this video I
want to talk a little bit about the body
mechanics behind performing split time
opposites this is usually considered to
be one of the most if not the most
challenging timing and Direction mode
that people pick up
um and I've found some tricks for
helping people learn it so I want to
share at least one of them with you in
today's video but before we jump into
that I do just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyro
Terra light toys spin balls and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by trying looking
at the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinsky and
Becca becklinen thank you all so very
much for your support for my work and my
mission all right so this is another one
of those things that recently popped up
on my live stream classes over on
crowdcast
um and you know I I remember when I was
first learning POI that learning how to
do split time opposites was kind of a
really unique Challenge in a lot of ways
because you know after all you can just
tell somebody to move their hands around
together to get them to do together same
this feels relatively intuitive and tell
them you know hey flap your arms like
the wings of a butterfly and that'll get
them to together opposites heck you can
even tell them to do the crawl stroke
and that will get them into the world of
doing split Time same direction but
there's really really few things that we
learn in the course of Our Lives that
really set us up for the motion of time
opposites the one exception of course I
always think of is just double Dutch
jump roping but not everybody does that
Growing Up So finding a proper way to do
that can be a little bit of a challenge
for a lot of people not the least of
which because you know as people are
working from very very little
kinesthetic information it's really
tempting every time your arms separate
to switch into split Time same direction
because that feels a lot more intuitive
to us
but I do have some tricks and like I
showed in the last video about how to do
together same there's also some
kinesthetic tricks here that not only
will make split time opposites more I
guess more intuitive may not be the way
to put it perhaps more uh more
accessible
but also doing it in such a way that
it's going to set your body up for
success with a lot of things down the
road too yeah all right so let's take a
look at this now you may remember if you
if you haven't seen it already I'll go
ahead and link to it both down in the
description as well as up in the cards
the lesson that I did about moving your
arms in together same and how I pointed
out the good way to do that is to turn
your upper body back and forth as you're
performing together same
specifically because it it saves you
some work in terms of like if your upper
body is moving your hands around it it
saves you from having to like really
really reach back and forth with your
hands as you you would if you just kept
your shoulders Square to your audience
as I'm doing right now
which you know a lot of people that uh
when they learn split time opposites
will try and do something similar where
they're basically and and this is
actually really interesting if you look
at it from the side because it means
that they're reaching pretty far out in
front of them in order to kind of keep
split time opposites going here
um
and very frequently that means that you
don't leave a lot of room between your
hands and you're going to need that room
when you get into a lot of flower work
um so here's how we get there uh number
one
we need to go back to our old friend
moving our upper body back and forth
like so in fact every time I switch
sides with split time opposites I am
switching up which shoulder is pointing
towards my audience yeah and of course
I'm doing the same thing I always do
where I'm keeping my head isolated and
stable as my shoulders are moving back
and forth right
now what's going on with my hands well I
think this is a dance from the 50s
called the mashed potato don't don't
like quote me on that but um literally
it's just this I'm just slicing my hands
back and forth but notice I'm keeping my
hands square with my shoulders the
entire time I'm just working them back
and forth like so if you look at it from
the side it looks like this
quite Vogue right
um
and then I just turn my upper body back
and forth I swear this is all this is
all there is to this pattern but um
let's let's pick it apart nonetheless
yeah so I'm going to start with my upper
body turned over here to the left and
I'm going to start with my right hand up
my left hand down and I'm going to sweep
my hands past each other I want to see a
point at which my hands go past going
straight out away from me
like that and then back to having my
hands apart now I'm going to turn my
upper body to point my left shoulder
towards the camera and again I'm going
to sweep my two hands past each other
like I'm you know drawing uh uh opening
closing a shark's mouth or something
like that and I want to have a visual
check that I see my two hands swing past
each other right about at shoulder level
yeah this is important
now that right hand is going to reach up
left hand is going to reach down I
really really do need to emphasize here
that one of those things that you're
looking for is to make sure that
whichever hand is going towards the top
it's actually going towards the top it
is reaching above your head it's not
head level it's not shoulder level it's
reaching up we are actually exploring
our vertical space here yeah awesome now
that the right hand is up I want you to
turn your right shoulder to face the
camera and sweep the two hands past each
other
turn that left shoulder to face the
camera
right hand comes up
right shoulder faces the camera
left left hand comes up left shoulder
face at the camera you notice the
pattern here when my right hand goes up
I point my right shoulder towards the
camera when my left hand comes up I
point my left shoulder towards the
camera and it's funky because as you're
doing this this is going to feel so
different from whatever attempts you may
have made in wall plane to either
approximate Double Dutch jump roping or
even just like try and keep count with
your split time it literally just
becomes I sweep and turn I sweep and
turn I sweep and turn I sweep and turn
like so
um
even though the appearance of it is more
or less the same the the feeling of it
is so very very different so again
we let's start from here actually right
hand goes up point the right shoulder
left hand goes up point the left
shoulder right hand goes up point the
right shoulder left hand goes up point
to left shoulder like so now your work
is to try and start to make
that turn happen instantaneously on
either side as you go back and forth
yeah and once you get a good feeling for
this
guess what you will find yourself doing
split time opposites
um
I I went through the steps there quite
quickly like you really do just want to
think that it's like okay turn
turn
and then see if you can maybe count it
down your head think like one thousand
two one thousand three one thousands
turn one one thousand two one thousand
three one thousand turn one thousand two
one thousand turn one one thousand two
one thousand turn one thousand turn one
thousand turn and then just zero turn
zero turn zero turn zero turn and when
this starts to feel comfortable you can
start just trying to go straight back
and forth and of course get your head
used to tracking straight towards the
camera slash audience as you're doing it
right
um of course the benefits of this are
exactly the same as they were for doing
together same in that it creates that
when you have your hands square with
your shoulders it creates that middle
portion where once you get around to
doing your flowers
you're going to note that that space in
the middle is really really helpful for
doing your flower petals like so yeah
and again as you're watching me do this
it's not something that's super obvious
to the audience that I am switching the
orientation of my shoulders each time as
opposed to if I were to do it like this
where there's a real clear gap between
my hands as they go to either side and
maintaining that space between my uh and
maintaining the relationship of those
two POI in that space is not that easy
as opposed to moving those shoulders
back and forth like so doesn't that just
look more pleasing doesn't everything
just kind of match up and and much in in
much uh more aesthetically pleasing ways
yeah yeah
so that is my tip for getting down
having your arms in Split time opposites
um yeah it's it's a little bit of a
process I I absolutely will cop to that
um but I think it looks good in the long
run I think that this teaches you form
that is going to make your flowers look
awesome and you know it's also going to
give you uh it's going to save your
shoulders in the long run too from
having to do a lot more extra effort so
I'm a fan yeah you can tell me what you
think of uh of of this means of uh
learning to do split time opposites
yourselves
um yeah so if you would like to check
out those live stream classes that I'm
teaching these days you can do that by
heading to crowdcast.io slash directs
Factor POI and you can register for
whatever classes happen to be current at
the moment which as I'm recording this
I'm in unit 3 which is all about doing
Tic Tacs and eventually it's going to
take us into you know Chuck turns and
windmills and like basically the
beginnings of body tracers and
everything so yeah you should check that
out and if you got anything out of this
video please make sure to like comment
share and subscribe to help other people
find this video and of course to help my
channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible were it
not for the awesome support of all of
these nice people right here these are
my flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support if you're out there
watching are not currently a supporter
but would like to become one because I
mean why wouldn't you you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactor POI I will leave the link to
that down in the description as well as
up in the cards if you're watching on
YouTube there you can get uh hold access
to a whole bunch of awesome rewards as
well as you'll be helping me out in my
mission of bringing POI spinning and
flow Arts to The Wider world and helping
people connect with their brains and
their bodies so go check that out please
and thank you
if you're a fan of this style of lesson
I have a whole playlist full of other
lessons just like this one I will leave
a link to that playlist down in the
description as well as up on screen here
if you're watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that based upon
your past viewing habits you'll really
like this top video here so maybe give
that a shot as well either which way
thank you so much for watching have
yourself a good one get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
very soon
peace